so Joan as we as we walk through
geometric algebra I think the the best
place to start might be through a more
tangible example so you're doing a
project with drones here at Cambridge
can you explain that first yes so we're
doing a project with drones this is
joint with the architecture department
and what we'd like to do is use drones
to look at the built environment
generally and the built environment has
is made up of lots of lines so what we
would like to do is to do a lot of our
processing or vision processing with
lines and lines are much more difficult
classically in computer vision and
points a lot of reconstruction is done
with points you get a point cloud you
can get structure from motion so motion
capture for instance when you see
someone in the suit with all the ping
pong balls they're connecting points
they are they're all points exactly but
then even not with motion capture just
with cameras that are moving you can get
points you can match points okay so we
would like to do this with lines lines
are difficult and our mathematical
framework that we will use for this is
geometric algebra okay
so let's define it yeah start there yeah
me shall i define it okay and we'll see
if it ties in with Shiva make sense what
about it
so um draw some history yeah that's so
so um so grassman was a mathematician
and grassman had something called an
outer product so for example I can take
two vectors mm-hmm I can put a wedge
between them a wedge product or an outer
product and I get a wedge B mmm so this
quantity is now a different thing and
I'll explain what that is so grassman
had this outer product and Clifford
William Clifford who was actually at
Trinity before I moved to London um so
he came along and he extended this outer
product he effectively had
and in a product plus an outer product
so for example if I have two vectors hmm
a dot B mm-hmm where the dot is an inner
product giving me a scalar and a wedge B
which gives me this other thing is a
Clifford product so seems like a strange
thing to do they only had an algebra for
this this Clifford product which is
called Clifford algebra and has been in
the mathematics literature and research
program for ever since Clifford died
which was in the 1870s he died at the
age of 34 I think but M of T B so he did
a lot but clearly could have done much
more right so but as a as a kind of you
know applied tool um it wasn't wasn't
really used and it was David Hester us
who came in the 1960s and said gosh you
know look at this Clifford called it
geometric algebra I'm gonna call it
geometric algebra and I'm gonna do all
these wonderful things for this so
effectively L Tet so that's the the
background the the basis is so imagine I
have scalars mmm
so just numbers vectors so things with a
magnitude and a direction in 3d we can
think of this yeah by vectors their
planes okay right so things that I have
two vectors that mix a plane yep so a
plane would have a position and a
magnitude and a handedness yeah what is
that handedness is so suppose I have
three points that make up the plane okay
I can I can sort of go from A to B to
see more from A to C to B got it okay so
if I take a wedge B to form my plane in
vectors huh then B where J will give me
minus the plane mm-hmm okay so it's it's
a you have to then start to think of
these planes as as geometric objects
which have a sign as well so in so if
take vectors a wedge B wedge C it gives
me a volume again it will be an oriented
for you mm-hmm
if I live in four dimensions a which be
great to see which D give me a four
volume okay so at some point I get to
the highest element in the space in 3d
that would be a volume I can't go any
bigger and that has a special that has a
special place in my algebra so imagine I
have in 3d scalars vectors plus bi
vectors
plus try vectors so points lines planes
volumes I have an algebra which takes
these things as objects and I can add
them I can multiply them I can
differentiate respect to them so it's
the kind of abstract concept but it is
amazingly powerful okay that's that see
the kind of rough ideas right how
Clifford algebra moved to geometric
algebra and and this is all predating
computers so this isn't being rendered
anywhere yet you mean in hardware yeah
so we have we have a community not a
massive community but there are lots of
people who are very interested in in you
know potentially getting instructions
for chipsets etc and PGA is it is okay
so and of course we have quite a lot of
programs that people have been building
so that the community can test these
things out and so what rekindled it in
the 60s to make make it happen now um so
Dave chestnuts was doing his PhD and he
was a physicist and looking at
space-time so basically his his PhD
turned into a book called space-time
algebra from which basically in the 80s
people got hold up and started to get
interested in
even though David had been working on it
throughout since the sixties and what
started David on the Clifford algebra I
am actually not quite sure okay I'll ask
him yeah and then so but you mean what
so but that he very quickly realized
that this algebra simplified a lot of
space-time physics right so I don't know
what I wanted to get it y ya know what
was the realisation that made like why
is this important now why is this
important so in effect space-time
physics quantum physics relativity is
extremely complicated and is you know
it's the area there where you do have to
have a lot of background knowledge and a
lot of background mathematical knowledge
you do need to be proficient in for
example for general relativity you need
differential geometry you need a lot of
these mathematical systems you need a
lot of tensor analysis so I mean David
could see that with this algebra he
could work entirely within an algebra of
geometric objects transformations
between these objects everything stayed
in the algebra transformations i linear
transformations functions were
geometrically intuitive there were
mappings of objects objects they weren't
just tensors and we didn't have to go to
another space you know a sort of dual
space as you do in differential geometry
so things became that easy and he
started to see that you could interpret
a lot of things like Dirac matrices well
actually they're not matrices at all
they were you know elements of the
algebra and immediately they became easy
to deal with so his big motivation was
that here was a unifying language for
mathematics and
basically so if you know this language
you can not only do rigid body dynamics
and engineering and classical mechanics
you can do linear algebra without
matrices and without tensors and you can
do complex things in quantum space-time
physics with the same mathematical
system and this is not theorized this is
proven at this point you know it's all
good like this idea that maybe this
might work someday no right but the part
of the problem is that we all I mean you
might you your next question might be
well if it's so wonderful
well why doesn't everyone use it right
um so a Clifford died when he was 34 and
it was at the point where Gibbs
Heaviside came in and I produced vector
algebra and the cross-product and so
have you ever thought about the
cross-product nope so so if I have two
vectors and I take a cross B it gives me
the vector which is perpendicular to the
plane effectively now that's all very
nice but it only works in 3d it doesn't
work in any other dimension right
because in a plane right stuck in four
dimensions there's no concept of a
perpendicular to a plane okay so but of
course we will grow up with vector
calculus linear algebra and matrices and
then we have our research areas and it's
very difficult to actually to listen to
somebody if they come along and say I've
got this super duper new mathematical
system that you are to you know take
notice
yeah yeah yeah someone comes up to me
and says look at this no I will say well
you know I've got my own research and it
takes me all my time to you know okay do
what I'm doing okay and so what planted
the seed in you that you wanted to
follow this path um so you killed the
truth sure sure that is a goal yeah okay
so the truth is my husband um met david
testers anthony um Lazenby he
he became fairly obsessed with geometric
algebra he is a cosmologists he could
see that there was this thing which told
him what the Koshi Riemann equations are
a few yeah for people who know it and
that poly matrices and the Dirac
matrices in in space-time quantum
physics were just really interpretable
hmm and he became obsessed with it
totally obsessed so Anthony had a PhD
student called Chris Doren Chris and
Anthony they wrote they've written a
book on on geometric algebra geometric
algebra physicists physicists and it was
very difficult for me to actually talk
to my husband at that point without
actually finding out something about it
okay because he thought it was one of
the most exciting things he'd ever seen
mm-hmm and you were at the time pursuing
math PhD what were you I was pregnant at
the time so I was just about to have a
baby so I did have some time actually
yeah because I was you know not that
much time course when you got a small
child yeah but yeah I wasn't it I was
gone back as an engineer I was a postdoc
huh no engineering I was doing imaging I
was imaging flames that was a two 2-year
postdoc position but I actually then
began to realize that these this algebra
would be really useful in parts of
engineering particularly things which
involve rotations and maybe I should
talk about rotations because in
engineering and physics rotation the way
geometric algebra deals with rotations
is totally key so have you heard of
quaternions I've heard of them yeah so
quaternions are but for go back people
rotate with rotation matrices yeah you
have say in three but in three
dimensions you have a three by three
matrix you act on a vector and it
rotates it
now a rotation has just three degrees of
freedom we have nine nine components and
a 3x3 matrix and so they're all
constrained so rotation matrices are not
numerically nice to deal with because
you have to keep them on the manifold
you have to make make sure if you change
if you update the rotation matrices you
have to make sure it it's at a basic
constraints okay so one of the things we
use now in graphics etc and satellite
motion it's long been known that the
best things to use as quaternions other
methods or Euler angles okay a rotation
about the x axis the y axis is dead axis
but quaternions have been particularly
nice because they are minimally
parametrized they have three components
they are smooth they don't suffer from
singularity problems and Hamilton and
creator quaternions as an extension of
complex numbers so complex numbers
everybody people know that complex
number I I effectively rotates in the
plane a multiplication by I so Hamilton
spent many many years in his later life
trying to extend complex numbers to
three dimensions hmm and he came up with
quaternions so quaternions have these
elements ijk which all square to minus 1
so it's like three mm-hmm imaginaries so
now to start with that's pretty awful
and but everybody knew they were great
great to those libraries people have
been using quaternions cincy since the
early days of satellites okay so if you
actually look at code etc you know
people will use this for rotations now
very early on it no it's in David's book
that you see that if I if I square one
of these by vectors in 3d that's taken
3d for now
um if I square it hmm
if it's a unit back there I get minus
one so I have a real object that squares
to minus one okay we kind of telling me
that I complex the unit imaginary and
this JK are probably unit planes and it
turns out that the quaternions are just
rotations the ijk give you rotations
about the unit planes in three
dimensions the XY the Y Zed on the XZ
plane
mm-hmm so immediately you see that you
can have complete generalizations of
things that do rotations in any
dimension and so at that point you're
doing this postdoc position and you
realize that you could apply it yes not
to flames but to no okay to mainly
computer vision okay
and what-what was a stage like the state
of computer vision at this time what
year was this 93 1993 okay so not much
happening a lot of the-- you know it was
it was um really starting to move
forward there was no machine learning
and computer vision that but was all
geometry basically all geometry so
people had used projectable you know
people had been using the ideas of
projective geometry in computer vision
for a long time which is a four
dimensional base silk with matrices so I
rotate and translate things and I have
lots of cameras I want to find from my
images the rotations and translations
between my cameras once I've done that I
could triangulate and I can do 3d
reconstruction okay
it was also at that stage a lot of um
Bayesian statistics were coming in to
computer vision so tracking things in up
in images yeah and finding most probable
the most probable tracks right in you
know crowds ok so computer Fishman's
really starting to take off okay
and so you
you're you finish up your two-year
you're creating these flames these
graphics essentially what do you jump
into to actually give it a go so I was
extremely lucky because that by that
point I had two small children um I I
don't know if you heard the Royal
Society no in but you the Royal Society
um the body in London oh okay yeah so
you're probably you probably have
because it's it's has journals and lots
of you know historical people with big
names in history were Fellows of the
Royal Society so the Royal Society has
something called university research
fellows and I applied to do it was
probably quite a step for them because I
probably apply it to do applications of
geometric algebra in engineering and
they gave it to me five-year effectively
postdoc and I could choose what teaching
I did and the engineering department
were very good you know I didn't didn't
need to do a lot of teaching or admin
but I basically had kind of five years
to try and get this off the ground to
kind of figure it out and what yeah what
was an example of an early project so um
so another project was actually with I I
think at the time the internet wasn't
really like it right like it was a day
um but there was a mailing list and
there was somebody who call Eduardo
baroque or attano who is now in Mexico
but he put this email out on some
listing anybody working with computer
vision and geometric algebra so I
actually you know contacted him and
those early days we we did quite a lot
of translating all the classic
projective geometry computer vision
which was quite mathematical at the time
um into geometric algebra gotcha okay
and I mean this may sound kind of basic
but
love the really nice things about
putting putting your problem etc into
geometric algebra is you have an origin
right so some inertial frame everything
is with respect to that I rotate
translate that right I don't have
matrices so I have to worry about
coordinate systems
I don't stack up coordinate system upon
coordinate system and then worry about
what on earth that coordinate system is
sat in yeah and with vision where you're
measuring things in an image and that's
so what coordinate frame is that in yeah
yeah it's it is right quite confusing
and I know this for a fact because
students are very confused about at all
when you've got a rotation where's it
with respect to in these complicated
systems etc this just makes life very
very easy okay and you you almost can't
go wrong it was the goal of this five
year period to then apply it to some
like product use or just do the basic
research and see how it goes really well
if what happened at that time
it was just really seeing what we could
get out of it okay so I did some work
with a company called phase space whose
mote that they're a motion capture
company in the States and not far from
Berkley and you know looking at
algorithms to calibrate cameras mm-hmm
because one of the things I haven't
mentioned is that there is another
aspect to this system which is extremely
useful so I've said that I have these
geometric objects my rotations are
objects so I can write down coordinate
free expressions but not only can I
write them down I can differentiate with
respect to them easily okay so because I
have this algebra of objects yeah I can
do calculus on them okay and that's
quite hard to do conventionally because
you've got people can do it but you know
you're differentiated respect to a
matrix or a tensor or a vector and all
this so it's a much harder you can do it
component wise mhm but if I want to get
close form solutions
I'm doing a current the analytic stage
of the calculus is extremely useful hmm
and so the the notion was that you could
do it with less compute like you could
render these things using geometric
algebra faster never okay but so you
look pretty fast it's more it's much
easier to program up okay it's intuitive
you can think of what you want to do and
I can program a topic in this high level
yeah underlying you've got an algebra of
a much bigger algebra than three
dimension space right right of course
so actually computation more going on is
more going up okay yeah but at a higher
level you know I can I can get code to
do all this for man at higher level
yeah I can certainly right rotate this
object to this object okay and then in
terms of it like this state of computer
vision from then until now what is
progressed to make this this drone
project possible okay so this is an
interesting question
um so david test nuts and garrett
Sobchak wrote a book um this is a sort
of real reference book of clifford
algebra to geometric calculus yes got
everything in there it's not a book
you'd read it's a book it's a book that
you go to make a reference yeah yeah I'm
sure they meant it for you to read and
it that was 1984 or so in 1999 David
gave a talk at a conference he done a
paper with Hong Boley about something
which was in the final few pages of this
book hmm of course not many of us had
ever got to the final few pages of this
book we should call conformal geometric
algebra so this is truly stunning for
graphics and for vision II projects
projects which use vision so conformal
geometric algebra is a five dimensional
space so imagine you take Euclidean
space with space we live in you
effectively add on two more vectors one
is the origin one as a point at infinity
projective geometry
effectively adds on one more vector so
this is this five dimension space so you
get this five space and you think well
okay what you know what is this gonna
get me well what this gets you is that
points lines planes circles and spheres
become objects in the algebra they're
objects you give me a No see this Big C
is a circle it's a try vector in my five
dimensional space and rotors which are
these this class of objects that rotate
encompass rotations translations
dilations and in the rotations
translations dilations so you've
suddenly got I I can for example set up
you give me three puts I immediately get
the circle that joy that go passes
through you give me four points and give
you the sphere it's an object
I use my rotor I rotate it I intersect
them it's a beautiful language for
graphics mmm okay so but because a lot
at night from 1999 lots of you thought
well fair number relative yes leo dost
and Steve a man and Daniel Fantine in
Steve in Canada Leo Italian Amsterdam
and wrote a book geometric algebra of
computer scientists a lot of that was
based on this conformal just what you
could do
yeah just how easy it was to do things
so um because lines are just objects
because I know how to sort of compare
one line to another because I can
intersect lines and planes keeping this
nice algebra mm-hm you know it becomes
quite almost easy to see what I have to
do to implement a variety of algorithms
so you've mean
it's quite hard to intersect two spheres
people can do it but it's easy to
imagine how it works but yeah fern yes
yeah but you know you've got equations
but here we just do have operators that
do it we're between objects and one of
the beautiful things is we live in a
Euclidean extensive what we see idiom
now if you have a different underlying
geometry yeah so if you have hyperbolic
or spherical geometry then in this
algebra you have to change you have in
conformal algebra Euclidean geometry is
the thing that keeps the pointed
infinity invariant then if I keep other
things invariant I get these other
geometries and I can just use my
standard apparatus and do exactly the
same things rotates I rotate my objects
in hyperbolic space and rotate my
objects the cervical space move them
around like so it is it's a beautiful
language mmm
geometry okay and I haven't even touched
on physics because a lot of you know de
sitter space a lot of the cosmologists
work in is a different geometry okay
gadget which you couldn't use this for
right which is why it was appealing to
your husband 30 years ago no exactly so
he you know he started out by being
amazed at how things like Cowley and the
Dirac matrices spinners were all just
trivial in this algebra then he started
to realize that these complicated
transformations tense which are all
written in tensor notation or actually
if you put them in geometric algebra
they are mappings between real things
like by vectors to by vectors or by
vexes vectors and things like this and
as soon as you see it in this way it be
Able's you to sort of you know interpret
things and then maybe move move on and
so for example so Anthony and Steve goal
Chris Doran and Dave testers are
interested in in a theory of gravity in
flat space which produces also you know
their theory of gravity you could
understand if you understood the algebra
yeah basically okay gotcha
and so the as you were saying before
like the reason why people aren't
picking up geometric algebra is that you
become kind of in a certain track and
that you know what you know but but
right now what are people using for
modern computer vision to do comparable
work um so computer vision is really
massively advanced of course yeah so
today people are really now moving from
geometry to machine learning you know
you use using a little bit of geometry
but you are learning to segment things
recognize things by giving it lots and
lots of images but you know you still
have you we still have lots of geometric
problems so we still have to extract
things from images if we've got moving
cameras yeah and things like that but we
have I suppose it's a case of geometric
algebra won't really give you anything
that you can't do conventionally mm-hmm
what it might enable you to do is to see
how how to do that thing so for example
if I ask you how close is one line to
another mm-hmm I have a way of doing
that in my algebra if I could I could
sit down and write it in conventional of
course yeah
so but but could I have actually thought
of that conventionally probably not
because I'm not clever enough okay so
you know I I need I need a set of tools
which makes sense to me geometrically
and physically and I can then think me
and you know other people
think about how to extend that okay
and so in your day to day research how
are you then applying machine learning
because it many of your your PhD
students are working on exactly that
okay so it's almost impossible to avoid
machine learning yeah yeah you could try
but you can't avoid it so I have over to
um a sort of strength so some students
are applying conventional machine
learning techniques conventional you
know they they change all the time
neural networks recurrent neural
networks LS TMS to classical data like
medical time series data and III don't
know how you can use geometric algebra
for that right okay so um and you know
doing image segmentation etc so
classical image segmentation well you
know I'm not sure how you can get your
metrical algebra into that but as soon
as it comes to anything involving like a
moving camera moving drone multiple
moving cameras having streams of images
you want to match things you want to
triangulate missing then it is almost
the only way I know how to do it okay so
so it's that aspect of it and then can
we extend it so can we then you know we
know how how to parameterize in this
algebra on my lines my planes etc can I
learn them so can I learn these
geometric objects so we we're keen on
analyzing both sort of moving images
which we're going to extract lines
planes and also motion mm-hmm
so motion can I actually parameterize my
problem in terms of my geometric objects
and learn them mm-hmm okay and so for
instance like you know someone doing
computer vision with a self-driving car
like are they applying the same
techniques that you're applying to get
these lines or what would they use
I think no so so so we have this huge
amounts of research yeah yeah and who
knows what they're doing um but
primarily it's people are using if it's
not like if it's not lidar right yeah no
it's single camera multiple camera a
lots of data Bayesian methods for
segmentation following lines is easy you
know it's not that's not matching them
or trying to reconstruct them you just
kind of following them it's really
recognizing if it's a person if the road
if it's a tree and and you've got
multiple sensors so you know exactly
where you are GPS is right is really
accurate these days so no no yeah I
think I I don't know well I mean so the
question I'm kind of getting around to
is like where are the other applications
right so like you can in your instance
like you're rotating a camera you want
to map something it makes a lot of sense
like and then you can move it around
with because you have the lines you can
recreate the shape what are the other
use cases well yeah I do think that it's
real use is this the fact that it
unifies it's a unifying language so if I
know this I can just work things out
more easily instead of trying I mean if
people have worked with computer vision
they will know that often things that
work so instead of a rotation matrix are
they try your transpose instead of a
translation vector T they try or
transpose T and they mess around till it
works because in highly confusing okay
um
you've got no such problem here it's
very straightforward now okay that's not
that's not a good reason to use it if
you're proficient enough with classical
techniques but ie
I can go into feels like thin shell
elasticity no and there is a student who
is here at moment doing this
that is quite involved field but we put
it in terms of like I have these rotors
I have a surface I can stretch them I
can translate them then it's just in the
language of computer vision it's not a
differential geometry it's not in
anything else it's it's totally
understandable process right okay
so you could you could see a world where
then you know an artificial intelligence
understands this and then can apply it
anywhere and then you can then
understand it I yeah yeah I think that's
where its strengths planets yeah and in
and in new physics I I think I think you
know that because it unifies lots of
different quantum mechanics and
relativity and you know it hasn't it's
not it's not unifying quantum gravity
but you can see that it's a it is a
system whereby you might be able to
think of different ways forward right
okay so it's actually a better tool in
math okay people are extremely clever so
they will find ways of doing things that
are stunningly clever hmm boss or
complicated right into what where do you
see limits right now I think I don't
think it's it's not computationally low
because we're building up more and more
tools so I think I can give you a
website and you know you can try it out
yeah and you have to install anything
because it's an online you know your -
notebook so you can you can have a play
with it so we are you know we are a
community which is certainly moving
forward um this still doesn't don't want
a lot of us um so it's not taught it's
not taught so you know teach my fourth
years image processing but I don't teach
them geometric algebra okay
and is there an interest there to learn
or they're just like I don't know when
you don't know about it you you can't
really be interested in it
okay so it's a it's a and students have
no hang-ups they learn it and I think
great you know it's another tool yeah
yeah and use it okay hmm so um it really
it enables you I mean I have a lot of
confidence that if you give me a paper
on no sin shell elasticity it's gonna be
tough because it's tensors everywhere
and I've got frames and frames and
frames and jewel frames and things but I
can eventually understand it mm-hmm
so these different fields if I was as a
colleague Allen macro be he was using
sort of form of it in structures hmm so
there are fields electromagnetism is
also I should have should have mentioned
this what is a field whereby you really
get huge simplification so I am fairly
confident I can model electromagnetic
fields and do maybe some new engineering
hmm things using this if I had time okay
well that I was we were talking about
programming before we started recording
at lunch and about going from MATLAB to
Python right have people tried to create
a port in other words like oh you have
this traditional equation we can port it
over and then you can understand it and
see the value has that happened yet um
no okay
not really not really I mean there are I
mean most of the code is enabling you to
do things in a kind of transparent way
like I can wedge together two vectors oh
yeah yeah I couldn't conform or I can
form my sphere visualizing yeah and I
can do numerical I can do lots of
numerical computations with it fast so
we can now do it quickly but porting
things is a kind of difficult one yeah
like you're saying well you know here's
my equations in terms of poly spinners
what does it look like in geometric
algebra
well kind of looks the same except your
spinners aren't spinners there you know
so it's a difficult that's a very hard
yeah question to answer right because
it's not so simple it's like oh this is
how you call this function it's not the
same at all right okay so this is sort
of a weird random tangent but before
when we met you were telling me that a
couple years ago someone posted on
Hacker News one of your papers yeah what
was it what was it about how did all
this happen
so it was an invited paper and the
millennium edition 2000 of Philosophical
Transactions that are all Society so we
wrote a paper which was telling is just
saying how geometric algebra was a
unifying language and look at all these
great things we can do in computer
science engineering and physics yeah
and this is the way the world works and
this is you know you should do it
so some citation it sat there until um
bizarrely it was posted yeah and it was
a friend of mine and who reads these
things texted me and said well your
paper is number one read on this how can
use and I said well what's that is that
good or is that bad
I don't know so hard to know how it how
it emerged and hard to know how many I
mean where the some people who looked at
that and now are in our geometric
algebra community through you know so I
took it interested and came along um
[Music]
throughout the world now there are
groups and you know in the nineteen
nineteen ninety there were not many yeah
there were little groups who were really
keen on it and but now there are groups
almost everywhere they're not big sure
but um interest did you did you read the
comments
we're not winner one up there I did yeah
I mean they ranged from wow this looks
really cool to this
crazy you know and impossible to
understand we know I thought well no
that doesn't know that wasn't the we're
not trying to communicate that to gosh
this looks as though it can do
everything you know so it there went
there went very detailed there's more
people beaming in and saying do we short
things although I don't know with our
ethanol that's the nature of the
internet you have to comment quickly
falls off the front page and then your
comments of course yeah in the next five
hours it was probably yeah God right
exactly
down to 100 right but but um well what
do the folks who are are there naysayers
is that a community sorry are there
naysayers of geometric algebra gonna be
a thing yeah say so I mean there are
people yeah there are lots of people who
think yeah looks interesting but really
I can do it anyway you know and I have
I'm I am the world's expert in you know
perrolli matrices or whatever yeah
why do I need to put my matrix in terms
of a vector and so you know people think
in different ways to them that is the
way of doing it that's always been the
way of doing it and so I don't think
there are people who say oh this is
complete rubbish there are just people
who say oh yeah but you know what's it
gonna get me okay and I don't think
people it's not the kind of thing where
you can say it's wrong because it's not
wrong it's just a tool which you know
depends whether you want to invest the
time cuz you think about multiplying the
vectors together and and things like
this yeah it's it's anti commutative
it's not a commutative algebra so me
that we use throw away everything you've
learned
mm-hm as a kid and through school and
through university so it it makes
perfect sense once you're into it
there's a little you know there's a
little hump that's a learning curve yes
learning if they throw some things away
yeah it's much easier for younger people
to do that sure that make sense cuz I
have no real prejudices right okay they
they say yeah he's another
another thing you know it's like machine
learning another algorithm I'll program
it up now him right um and so yeah I
didn't I think probably there are people
who who do think well why should I
bother mm-hmm
but everything they would say no it's a
wrong thing to do you know one shouldn't
do that one should use matrices them
okay so it and you're you know educated
opinion where do you see this really
taking hold in the next I don't know
like for thinking about it in the
practical sense so many people who are
listening to IC podcasts are like
entrepreneurs or engineers are studying
where do you see the people applying
things like this um so clearly in the in
the fields of fundamental theoretical
advances so no physics or at the aspects
of physics that we're not quite sure
about yes it's a bit where I see it will
have some effect and because enables you
to think and it enables you to think in
different ways in engineering I think
there are lots of fields and I don't
know whether is there a killer
application where if I could do it
everyone would say whoa this is the way
to go right I don't know um
as I say I I would what I would like to
say is that people people had it in
their toolbox yeah because um you know
there are lots of very very clever
people around who can cope with very
hard and sophisticated physics and maps
there are a lot of people who are maybe
not quite so clever and they need the
right tools in order to do these complex
things and I see it as actually this
provides sees people with a real you
know a lot of people have a lot of
geometric insight but maybe not the
mathematical sophistication I think this
will certainly sort of give them a big
advantage because it seems to me to be
the way the will
works.this if it's a unifying language
it's what we should be writing yeah our
equations in okay um so yes all that's
answered your cursor no no that's a
great that's actually a great answer
yeah I believe that and I like it a lot
too if you weren't working on this do
you have thoughts on where you might
apply your your energy well it's
interesting because I have always hard
I'm I'm a runner
mm-hmm so I've been a runner since I was
a kid I I am absolutely convinced that
even if you don't run you know as you
get older you need to move and you need
to keep your body moving independently
you need to make the muscles move
independently you need to keep healthy
and I I probably would be doing
something which tried to get everybody
out and moving and isn't that that was
not what you're expecting no it's great
yeah yeah but you know I look at people
and as I get older and life could be so
much better for them if they kept mobile
and they they looked after their body a
slight obsession of mine but anyway yeah
yeah I guess then my last question is if
someone wants to learn more about this
and actually start trying it out where
should they go well so lots of books
available and I I people probably be
annoyed with me if I don't mention their
books but the so the the David Tesla
three books space-time algebra probably
not the place to start new foundations
of classical mechanics and geometric
algebra Clifford algebra two geometric
calculus now they they're great books my
husband Anthony and Chris Doran have a
book geometric algebra physicists leo
door Steven man and Daniel Fontaine have
a book which is geometric relative of a
computer scientists ed wada bio-cop
Baraka Machado has books which are
more focus on robotics so there are lots
of books out there lots of review
articles lots of conference proceedings
lots of code now so people you can kind
of get code for yeah MATLAB C for Python
we've been using now a path a package by
an American guy called Alex Olson ovitch
who wrote a Clifford package and we've
been integrating it into a new mice one
of my students Hugo he met um has
created a web version so the big problem
with a lot of these things you have to
download the package you got the package
you've got to get the numpy you've got
to get you got to get all these other
thing you got to get it all working
gotta get it working and if you're on
Linux this tends to be not above your
windows it's like impossible yeah
possible but your average person would
probably say you know well no but we
we're working to try and guess a web
version so people can actually go on try
it out with some readme files and a bit
of graphics so you can see it so there's
loads of stuff out there at the moment
where can they find that if they want to
maybe out is it on your site or it is
Hugo so Hugo and Alex of being working
on this and I can give you the web
address okay we can put it in the blog
post yeah yeah courier they just
releasing it to the world
Eric yeah perfect so it'd be good to
have people test it out and by email
back and say this doesn't work yes all
right thank you so much for your time
okay been a pleasure
you